what is your secret for Success what do
you think delaying gratification being
willing to do the thing that I know I
want for later and being uncomfortable
today in any field but I do stick with
strict diet or exercising whatever the
thing that's in front of you that you
don't want to do being willing to still
do it because you can delay the
gratification
I don't stick with it what is your
secret like you say something to
yourself you're strict you punish
yourself I think you have to figure out
what you want more because if you're not
doing it there's something else you want
it might be okay for you to just
then it's like there has to be something
bigger that you want for me it's what I
want to achieve I know that we've got
stuff and I want to help as many of them
as we can I have to do more content and
make more videos and do stuff that might
be tiring in the moment in the moment
but is what I want to do long term
100 thank you